now conference is a great honor to make
the closing speech before our
traditional anthems to close the week
just as John Prescott did back in the
day although I think I look better in a
dress
I hope we're doing proud today I love
the traditions of our movement from the
Durham miners Gala to the tall puddle
Martyrs Festival
but
what conference there's one part of our
history that I will never celebrate and
that's losing elections
just think how it will feel meeting here
in this Hall in a few years time after a
term of a labor government back in power
now conference this is the labor party
so I've no doubt that we'll also be
discussing how further we'd like to go
once we've debated the CAC report for
around 20 minutes
but conference what I will say
is when the Tories deliver one percent
of what they promise
they talk endlessly about that one
percent and we never hear about the list
of broken promises
when we deliver 99 of what we promise we
talk endlessly about the one percent we
didn't instead
we set a high bar but just think about
the historic labor governments and their
legacy
they didn't please all of our movement
all of the time including me but those
labor governments made history the NHS
Social Security the welfare state
Council housing modern higher education
the open University
decriminalizing homosexuality outlawing
racial discrimination
introducing equal pay the national
minimum wage sure start the evolution
The Good Friday agreement civil
Partnerships equal pay us the Human
Rights Act and the world's first climate
change Act
foreign
if we're not proud of ourselves don't
expect anyone else to do it for us
and just think what that future Party
Conference could have to celebrate
we've shown this week how different
we'll be
not just in our vision
but with our plan for Britain
starting with the biggest challenge
facing not just our country but the
world will tackle the climate crisis
head-on
we will protect our people and our
planet and we will pull out all the
stops to build a fairer and Greener
Britain as care set out yesterday
through our green Prosperity plan we
will unleash a green Industrial
Revolution by reaching a hundred percent
uh clean Power by 2030. we will save 93
billion pounds of energy bills and
through Great British energy
we will give British power right back to
the British people
[Applause]
a conference I said on Sunday
that moment of choice is upon us
a moment to show the country that we are
ready to govern
well conference
I know I'm a bit biased but boy do I
think that we've shown that
now it isn't just that we have better
policies although we do
it isn't just that we will be more
competent
although we will
is that our values differ fundamentally
and our policies are not better despite
our values but because of them labor
values the country's values too
yet too often when it comes to elections
people feel that they have a choice of
heart versus head values our competence
I say to those watching at home
this week
we have shown it's a choice you will
never have to make again
and this past week the Tories have shown
it too
the conservative party are no longer
pretending to be competent and stable
today's Tories will plunge us into chaos
in pursuit of their Dogma divide the
country to rule it
and regards rules as for you and not for
them
[Applause]
I mean they said tough on crime they
brought crime to number 10.
Defenders of the free market the
Market's in free fall
England's green and pleasant land
fracket
from the party of stability to causing
earthquakes from the party of business
to a slap down from the IMF from the
party of serious government to the party
of parties
let's trust has even crashed the port
market now that is a disgrace
now you think net snelson the trough was
one of the things that they could manage
when interest rates were low
and borrowing was cheap
they sacrifice public services for
austerity now they're boring just as
interest rates are soaring to think this
was the party that claimed they were for
sale money
that's what one high-flying new Tory MP
certainly fought back in 2012
he wrote a pamphlet demanding a balanced
budget every year
he said
fiscal Prudence is the very least we
should expect from a Chancellor and if
they failed
they should face a 20 pay cut
I tell you what that Tory employee must
be absolutely furious with a new
Chancellor
except to use the new Tory Chancellor
and you know what I've got a funny
feeling you won't be taking that pay cut
either
because you see pay cuts are for other
people
he won't even let the budget Watchdog
tell him just how much of our money he
is handing over to the super rich
they used to say the Tories knew the
value of nothing but the cost of
everything now they don't even know that
now the next election
won't be a choice between a strong
economy or a fair Society
we don't have to choose one or the other
because you can't have one without the
other and not unequal economy is an
inefficient one
is perhaps the starkest difference
between us and the Tories never again
can we let them pretend that they are
the Patriotic Party I love my country
that's why I want so much better for it
but the Tories now think our biggest
economic problem is you the working
people in Britain
and while they think you are the
country's greatest weakness we know
that you are our greatest strength
and that's why Rachel and I will make
the minimum wage a real living wage
because we are not just the party of
higher growth but of higher wages too
now we know what the Tories think
the new prime minister and her
Chancellor said it out loud
the problem is that British workers are
idlers not grafters the irony from this
lot
let's just say she doesn't like handouts
then handed 150 billion pounds to the
energy Giants they believe in undoubts
all right
and it's the same with their other top
priority unlimited Bankers bonuses it's
the same old Tory ideology you
incentivize the richest by giving them
more money and you incentivize the rest
of us by taking it away conference it
hasn't worked before and it won't wash
now
foreign
forget it but we're now in 12 years in
Satori government even if we are on our
fourth prime minister
and where are they now David Cameron the
privatized prime minister sold to
greensill what was his greatest
achievement fooling the lib Dems not
exactly a high bar
if you care about power for power's sake
and have no principles no policies and
no plan you end up with a pointless
Premiership remembered only as a pub
quiz answer
and then of course we had Theresa May
I remember her telling us that if you
were a citizen of the world you were a
citizen of nowhere if only we'd known
about their green cards and tax
loopholes
their politicians becoming like their
donors residents of everywhere taxpayers
of nowhere
and then there's Boris Johnson
I do owe him one apology
I said he couldn't organize a booze up
in a brewery
turns out he could organize a bruise up
pretty much anywhere just a shame he
couldn't organize anything else
now we're a party with a serious plan
he had a plan for a serious party
I'll miss one thing though as inflation
ran out of control at least his jokes
were one thing that got cheaper every
week
but the real problem wasn't that his
jokes were so cheap it was that his
mistakes were so expensive he ended his
time claiming he was fast from office by
the Deep State the only deep state that
fasting from office was the one he left
our country in
sorry Comforts I had to use all of my
Boris lines now while he still
remembered and while everyone knows who
he is
before he becomes a footnote in the
failure of the history books
conference
so that's what the new prime minister
must be hoping for because he'll be sat
on the back benches plotting his
comeback with a glint in his eye
thinking I wasn't so bad after all was I
what a sorry State of Affairs
and what does Liz trust have to say
after a decade in government
apparently they were wrong all along
she's now asking for seven years to fix
it yet offering us even more of the
ideology that caused the problems in the
first place
she just she doesn't just think that
we're lazy she must think that we're
stupid as well
and that brings me to this new
government
openly chosen for loyalty not ability a
Ministry of all the talentless
frankly conference when I looked at the
benches opposite last week I thought the
clowns had escaped the circus not so
much Flying Circus a lying circus
now maybe I'm being unfair my new
opposite number
Her First Act was to get to grips with
the real crisis in our NHS
the spread
of a new and dangerous Contagion
not the Omicron variant
the Oxford comma
now that's a comma before the word and
in case you were wondering
something like this sentence
GPS are overwhelmed ambulances not
turning up beds are full waiting times a
rocketing the NHS is starved of
investment and it's all the fault of the
Tory decisions
foreign
to put that right
so here's another sentence that Therese
coffee won't like
a labor government will double the
number of District nurses train 5 000
new health visitors create 10 000
nursing places double the number of
medical students and we will pay for it
by reversing your handouts to the
wealthiest few
foreign
comma of that policy conference
and what a contrast to the government
you've seen this week
yesterday the country saw the care that
I know and see every day announcing a
hundred percent clean Power by 2030.
driven by a British Energy company owned
by the British people for the British
people he showed the true real
leadership this country needs
and on Monday Rachel showed how labor
would govern with competence class and
care
with her as the UK's first ever female
Chancellor
setting out our national wealth fund to
give the British public a share of the
wealth that they create and a genuine
living wage that matches the cost of
living
and I just want to thank my own front
bench team Rachel Justin Imran and Flo
and Fleur for all that they have done
we have set out our five-point plan for
National procurement to tackle waste
fleas and lies and Unleash the Power of
public spending Our Fair work standard
to raise working conditions across the
economy alongside our new deal for
working people and we haven't stopped
there
our whole Shadow cabinet has shown we
have a team with a plan
70 percent
home ownership our renters Charter a
clamp down on buy to let Council Housing
Council Housing Council housing
the Hillsborough law a domestic abuse
register and a new football regulator
sewerage sanctions
job center reform and a transformational
industrial strategy
insulation Innovation
inspiration all in one
thirteen thousand more police officers
to keep our communities safe
new Navy ships built by unionized
workers in British shipyards
closing the tax break for private
schools to fund education for all
preschool breakfasts for children new
bus services in public hands and as
contracts expire restoring public
ownership of the railways
conference R shuttle cabinet a show
model labor government will be radical
responsible realistic but delivering
this message
would be absolutely impossible without
all of you
our brilliant activists who campaigned
through the wind and the rain and that's
just outside this building
if you ever needed proof that an onshore
Wind Farm can deliver get outside the
Pullman
now I have too many people to thank
but I want to mention our brilliant
chair Alice Perry standing down from the
nuc
and Diana Holland who is stepping down
as party treasure after 12 years we all
owe her a debt of gratitude
we could probably do with her also in in
the Chancellor's office as well
and then finally a thank you to
Liverpool for hosting our conference
now while the Tories would be a shame to
show their faith here you've shown us
the warmth and the pride that defines
this city
conference this week we have shown how
together
we will transform this country
and the depth and the talent across our
whole party
and we've come together
to honor our history as only labor can
be no doubt
the times ahead are going to be tough
but now let's rise to the moment and
deliver for working people of Britain
let's build a fairer Greener future with
a labor government in power once again
thank you
foreign
[Applause]